big decision from the Supreme Court did
you hear this big story the Supreme
Court ruled that a company has the legal
right to have an offensive name yeah
yeah
in other words Trump Tower is going to
stay Trump Tower taking my Trump some
days my hair just won't lay down so I
can do my patented Donald Trump sure
yeah
I look like Bob's Big Boy today
[Applause]
yesterday president Trump's lawyer
insisted that Trump is not under
investigation yeah yeah yeah he added
and you can trust me I'm Donald Trump's
lawyer let's get my story vice president
Mike Pence has gotten a dog pants has
already taught it to sit fetch and sniff
out gay
[Applause]
of course big Bill Cosby news
Bill Cosby's sexual assault case has
been declared a mistrial after jurors
deliberated for nearly 52 hours 52 hours
yeah you see first time people have
spent that week I'm sorry I like this
joke and I'm gonna try it again
you're with me aren't you I had a lot to
drink before the show
Bill Cosby sexual assault case has been
declared a mistrial after jurors
deliberated for nearly 52 hours that's a
long time how is that it's not a rodeo
you overdid it now anyway they spent
fifth they deliberated for 52 hours 82
hours yeah yes the first time people
have spent the weekend with Bill Cosby
and not left well rested I went to a lot
of trouble to get that one out and the
crowd was like uh listen you know that's
what's on the menu today the Discovery
Channel y'all watch the Discovery
Channel just pretend it's a feisty group
today the Discovery Channel announced
that Michael Phelps will compete against
a shark in a swimming race yeah yeah
meanwhile Ryan Lochte will compete
against a shark in a spelling bee either
one of those could go either way
wait Eman I just this is in the news
today according to a new survey the most
sexually satisfied women in the United
States are right here in Los Angeles
all I want to say is ladies you're
welcome
[Applause]
you